[Music]
me having just idea upon id upon idea
because i'm always thinking of
a story to tell what story you know
should i tell next okay i'm working on
this script but what should come next
why is your writing mentor relationship
important to you
because
you need someone to
believe in you
and that's one of the things that's one
of the major things that
he provides is
he lets me know that you know he sees me
working
he believes that the work is good he
believes that i have
a gift a talent for this
and i think that's important you need to
have someone in your corner you know
it's it's great that he is who he is and
he's in the position that he's in
um
but you know can it can really be anyone
i think um as long as
as long as
they have that belief and and and they
let you know
that what you're doing
you know is worth it like you're you're
not wasting your time you're not wasting
your talent
you know
keep pushing
um
that's that's that's why it's it's
really important because he provides
that for me you know
um
and also i mean with him being in the
business and being being successful he
just has a lot of knowledge that he's
able to impart
you know whether it's
it can be anything from
how scripts are formatted and how you
people will will receive the script to
stuff on the business end you know this
is what you need to think about you know
you need to think about you know taxes
you need to think about you know
contracts blah blah so he's got that
kind of inside track and that's also
beneficial i mean
you know
aside from him believing in you and
you sort of you know showing up for him
whether it's online or in person
what was one or two things that
he gave you feedback on that really
changed things for you um
i would say my approach
to
uh certain genres of storytelling
uh
you know he um
read one of my scripts and just just the
advice he just i think this is what you
should do
in this you know situation this is uh
this is how
things are usually structured in this
genre and he knows what he's talking
about
and you know just following his advice
i think really helped improved that
script
and i mean i i saw it in things like
contest placement and
sending it to uh coverage services and
just noticing you know the change in
score it's just like oh
you know this uh this was helpful this
was
a beneficial tip you know just things
like that
um
i think what it is is that
he's gearing me to write things that
will be
accepted by the industry
right
uh the industry looks for certain things
and he wants to ensure that
i'm giving the industry what it wants so
that they can say hey yeah you know
we'll we'll take a look at the script
you know we we like this guy we like
your writing
so
is that a mistake a lot of screenwriters
make is that they're not writing the
right stuff for the right genre for them
i just think that there are there's
certainly
there's certainly things that
are looked for
i think that a lot of i think that a lot
of emerging screenwriters are hesitant
to do so because they don't want to
maybe fall into a formula
you know they don't uh they don't want
to save the cat you know
but maybe something like that is
necessary because that's what's looked
for you you know that element that makes
your protagonist
likeable or interesting you've got to do
something like that and i just think
that
i do think that you know a lot of
emerging screenwriters want to do what
they want to do like you know i'm going
to be different i don't you know
and it's like
let's let's give them what they want
and then once you've kind of established
yourself
go wild you know do do whatever you want
to do
so that's that's my belief
sure so if it's like a musician if
you're playing
say heart and soul on the piano
don't get too jazzy with it or whatever
until you've really mastered the song
right exactly
what compels you to write
i just have stories to tell
uh i have
worlds and characters in my head and
and
these characters are begging for their
stories to get out
and
[Music]
that's that's what i want to do i want
to help them get their stories out
and this has been happening since you
were seven
oh yeah
yeah
when i
when i was a kid
i used to create
uh like the cablevision
guides the schedule guides right
um if you have hbo they send you the
monthly guy to let you know what movies
are playing that month and what time
on what day
i would create
entire
guides filled with original ideas
original stories
it was it was a bit disruptive like it
was to the point where teachers would
come to my desk and say jay you can't
work on your you can't work on your tv
guide like during you know math like
what are you doing
but
as i said i would fill these guys with
all these stories that i would create
you know um
and they they're coming from a young
kid's mind you know so it'd be little
things like you know johnny got grounded
for not doing his homework you know and
that'd be the title movie grounded you
know and uh it's
showing saturday at 7 pm or whatever
but that's i think that's
where this all stems from you know me
having just idea upon id upon idea
because i'm always thinking of
a story to tell what story you know
should i tell next okay i'm working on
this script but what should come next
um
some days ideas just come to me boom
boom boom
i don't understand how or why but it
happens i'm not one of these writers
that
oh you know i have to write an idea down
because i'll forget it no i have too
many ideas like i'll never forget
i do though have a document
that has nothing but ideas it's like
titles and ideas
and i do refer to it every once in a
while just to see you know what what
should be the next project what should i
tackle next and the funny thing is i
will usually come up with an idea
that's not on that document
that i end up working on so
you know all these all these ideas are
just kind of sitting there
do you find these ideas compete with you
like you are working on one but then
there's this new one and it's competing
for your attention always
always
and i can only work on one project at a
time i can't work on projects
simultaneously like my mind doesn't work
like that
but the good ideas
they stay in my mind
they don't go away
so
like when i moved to to los angeles i
came out here with three specs
those were ideas that had been rattling
around in my head
you know for far far longer than you
know before i moved out here
and
i had ideas when i came out here and two
of those ideas
i've written since since i've been out
here
and again you know ideas that i had
long before the move the good ideas just
don't go away they're always in my head
how long did it take you to write those
three specs
huh
i'm not sure but
not very long
once
once i set out to write a script i've
got the idea i outline it
and when i have the outline it
it's nothing i mean i can
i can usually hammer out five to six
pages in a writing session
and you know if we're talking a 9500
page script
you know it doesn't it doesn't take very
long at all so
um
my most recent
script
i started at the beginning of the
pandemic
and when everything started happening i
stopped writing i was
kind of frazzled or whatever
but then i picked it up
several months later toward uh toward
the end of the year
and
so if i had to like you know how fast
you know
does it take like that script probably
probably
took about a month and a half
so when you came out here armed with
these three spec scripts
you came with the knowledge of you heard
so many people that meet with someone
and they say okay great what else do you
have exactly okay and you didn't want to
be
that guy that just like well no this is
it
okay
exactly
and i mean that's that's what's been
happening i have been sending a script
out and the people you know that have
responded that's always been their
question it's like oh this is great what
else do you have
you know
so um yeah i you've got to be prepared
you've got it got to have something to
send them and you also write
you have fiction you have like a books
that you have on amazon as well so right
yeah i do yeah i've got four books
uh this those books were written in in
that period where i'd kind of
fallen out of love with with with uh
screenwriting with movies
but i wasn't going to stop writing like
writing was still going to be i still
wanted to get these stories out and so
that's what happened and the funny thing
is working on these books that's what
reinvigorated my you know my love for
screenwriting it's just like hmm
let me you know get back into this as a
matter of fact
two of my books started out as
screenplays
and
i felt that the stories were better
served
as novels just that you know i just felt
that i could get a little deeper with
the characters you can do things in a
novel that you can't do in a screenplay
or in a film
and i just wanted to explore that uh so
that's what happened you know with that
but
yeah i reversed engineered a couple of
screenplays into into books
and you wrote these while you were in
new york city in new york
interesting and and some of these
protagonists are they're they're all
women-centered stories not all of them
no not all of them um
but i do tend to
write women characters like i don't shy
away from that if i feel that
you know this is the protagonist this is
you know who the story you know
needs to be about then you know i'll do
that but my first book uh guest list is
about a young woman
uh
it's it's funny because
guest list is is about me leaving miami
uh and going to new york but the book
itself is about a young woman
um
who makes that move who leaves uh miami
and and comes to new york
and she gets caught up in the whole
party scene that's what i was escaping
from when i left miami
the uh whole nightlife party scene
right pretty people empty promises
exactly yeah some backstabbing oh yeah
exactly
wouldn't know anything about it